bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france l'enjeu majeur de l'élection de
demain c'est la lutte contre
l'insécurité le contexte sécuritaire
s'est dégradée au burkina violence où se
mêlent jihadistes et tensions
communautaires
le burkina faso subi les conséquences du
conflit au sahel aujourd'hui oui
absolument le burkina faso se trouve au
coeur d'une région sahélienne qui est en
croire à une grave crise en termes de
sécurité depuis plusieurs années
maintenant bien de cette crise et
commencé du côté malien de la frontière
où ces déplacés du nord du mali vers le
centre du mali
quelques années plus tard et a laissé
également dépassé vers la moitié nord du
burkina faso qui particulièrement pied
depuis 2004 donc effectivement cette
situation qui a causé plus de 1600 morts
au mot qui n'a pas ce depuis il ya
depuis 2015 est au coeur des
préoccupations électorales des violences
qui sont à la fois le fait de d'actes
terroristes et aussi de tensions
communautaires se sont
deux choses assez distinctes ou bien on
peut dire que les aides que les
mouvements djihadistes sort justement
sur ces tensions communautaires et
mettre parfois la la main ou en tout cas
ont la mainmise sur certaines
communautés dans le pays alors je pense
qu'il faut être assez prudent sur la la
tentation de d'assimiler certains
groupes communautaires ou ethnique à des
tendances djihadistes ou autre cette
tentation l'aï les amalgames que cela a
pu causer ont abouti à d'énormes
problèmes au burkina mais dans
l'ensemble clairement la situation
sécuritaire est aussi bien marquer comme
indiqué très très justement par d'une
part les attaques des groupes armés
d'extrémistes violents mais aussi par là
la présence et une aggravation des
conflits locaux il existe énormément de
bons kilos autour de questions liées à
la gestion des ressources naturelles un
accès à la terre à des questions de
gouvernance locale et d'inclusion et
toutes ces questions doivent être très
très des manières cohésive si on veut
pouvoir trouver des solutions et jusque
là comment répond le pouvoir central
jusqu'ici la réponse mise en place a été
quand même très militarisée très axé
voilà sur une réponse vraiment
sécuritaire le bookeen a énormément
investi dans ce dans cette approche
sécuritaire qui est certes nécessaire
mais qui n'est sans doute pas suffisante
puisque également qu'on en compte les
enjeux de gouvernance plus profond qui
sont liées voilà à ces questions de de
confiture et alité locale quelques
rentes qui sont liées à ces questions de
relations intercommunautaires mais à
tout cela est venu se surimpose
également conséquence directe donc de de
l'insécurité de la violence qui avec
notamment des pensions civiles et une
crise humanitaire majeure qui n'a pas
souhaité actuellement
frappé par une dalle aux crises de
déplacement forcé importante avec plus
d'un million de da ce n'est pas ces
internes et évidemment la réponse doit
également prendre en compte cette
dimension
bender si si on veut réellement couvrir
l'ensemble du spectre de l'insécurité
humaine quelle solution de sortie de
crise propose les candidats à la
présidentielle demain chacun y va de sa
proposition mais globalement ce qui se
dégage c'est un peu
continuons dans la même direction avec
beaucoup de réponses sécuritaires
certains candidats ont évoqué le besoin
d'alliés à ça une approche de
développement reconnaissant que le
manque d'accès à l'emploi que la la
propreté et s'est constitué un terreau
favorable aux armées mais globalement on
a encore un peu de mal à sentir des
rites ablement un changement de cap vers
une réponse qui soit beaucoup plus
intégrée et qui permet de mieux répondre
à la variété des problèmes qui
constituent cette crise est la lutte
contre l'insécurité comme l'un des
enjeux électoraux majeurs du scrutin de
demain
très concrètement de façon pragmatique
c'est aussi tout simplement la sécurité
du scrutin qui se déroulera tout au long
de la journée de ce dimanche qui sera en
jeu tout à fait à cette question de la
sécurité du processus électoral s'est
posée bien avant le jour du scrutin
plusieurs incidents ont eu lieu ces
dernières semaines je mentionnerai
notamment l'assassinât le 8 novembre
dernier du chauffeur de l'un des
candidats dans la partie nord du pays
ainsi que quelques jours plus tard le 11
novembre une embuscade tendue aux forces
de
nous défense et de sécurité burkinabè
qui a fait 14 victimes parmi les
militaires
l' approche qui a été mise en place pour
pour gérer ce contexte d'insécurité elle
se situe à plusieurs niveaux d'une part
les la classe politique burkinabè s'est
entendus sur la nécessité d'avancer avec
le processus électoral même si le
spectacle ne peut pas se tenir partout
sur le territoire
de ce point de vue là donc un amendement
à la loi électorale a été passé devant
août avec une clause de force majeure et
de circonstances exceptionnelles qui
permet aux autorités électorales et à la
cour constitutionnelle de valider les
résultats de l'élection même si elle n'a
pas pu se tenir partout de manière plus
opérationnelle à la commission
électorale nationale indépendante a
également mis en place une carte qui
permet de suivre l'évolution de la
situation sécuritaire zone par zone
avant de défiler de définir où le
scrutin pourrait se tenir ou non de le
de leur côté enfin les autorités
nationales ont mis en place un plan de
sécurisation des élections qui mobilise
l'ensemble des forces nationales mais
autour duquel se pose certaines
questions notamment par rapport à rôle
que pourrait jouer certains acteurs non
étatiques notamment les volontaires pour
la défense de la patrie ou bien certains
groupes de chercheurs de korhogo dans
cette sécurisation des élections bien
sûr tout cela reste à voir
et suscite beaucoup de d'interrogations
et nous suivrons avec attention ce
scrutin il se tiendra donc demain double
scrutin législatif et présidentiel merci
beaucoup fornella en modérant chef de
programme celle à l'institut d'études de
sécurité